ce sont des scènes quasi quotidiennes
dans les écoles 1420 dossier pour
insultes ou menaces envers des
enseignants 270 pour agressions
physiques se jette sur moi
ou quand le contrôle bien m'attrape à la
gorge et avec notre mam tire les cheveux
et ne lâche pas des enseignants agressés
par les élèves
ces violences sont dénoncées depuis des
décennies j'ai été frappée à coups de
poing et coups de pied dans le ventre
mis ko en quelque sorte l'état toujours
tenter de faire revenir l'ordre dans les
établissements scolaires sans grand
succès il ya des matins où je me demande
aujourd'hui quand est ce qu'il va se
passer quelque chose
le premier à aborder le sujet c'est jack
lang en 1992 alors ministre de
l'éducation mais alternance politique
oblige la tâche reviendra à son
successeur en 1993 françois bayrou test
un dispositif les appeler et vous
comptez faire entrer les appeler à
l'école il y en a déjà
c'est à dire de ceux qui jouent le rôle
de grand frère qui sont là et qui aident
conseil entourent encadrent tester mais
pas pérennisé en 1999 claude allègre
prévoit de placer les forces de l'ordre
autour de l'école 8000 postes d'adjoints
de sécurité et de renforcer la loi
contre les agressions toute agression
sur un enseignant sera poursuivie
automatiquement que l'enseignant porte
plainte ou pas annoncer pas appliquée
mon idée revient en 2002 du côté du
ministère de la justice cette fois
dominique perben instaure l'outrageant
enseignants six mois de prison et 7500
euros d'amande et une interrogations
chez les profs et des parents d'élèves
nous avons quand même une petite crainte
qui est celle de decaux demain on puisse
condamner à six mois de prison
un enfant
par an pour avoir dit une parole un peu
déplacé un enseignant en réalité
difficile à appliquer car il faut une
plainte de l'enseignant ils sont
nombreux à préférer ne pas en arriver à
la justice le temps passe les agressions
continues alors en 2005 le ministre de
l'éducation gilles de robien veut faire
entrer les forces de l'ordre dans
l'école
contre l'avis des profs en face d'une
réticence éventuelle des enseignants moi
je vois aujourd'hui la crainte des
enseignants d'être agressés c'est un peu
ça l'histoire de la violence envers les
professeurs un diagnostic partagé
mais en désaccord sur les solutions de
2005 à aujourd'hui les gouvernements
envisagée ou tester la présence des
forces de l'ordre dans certains
établissements sans que le dispositif se
fasse une place durable à l'école
[Musique]